well very pleased because this country
has led the way really and two and a
half billion pounds worth of sport last
year and a further similar amount to
come and the first country to pledge
tanks Challenger twos which will be a
very effective resource for the
ukrainians but we do need to get these
uh this Weaponry over there as quickly
as possible as a collective effort the
German Leopard tank is very effective
and the Abrams from America will be very
effective too and then of course we've
got to train up the ukrainians to be
able to use these in double quick time
so they can get them out to the battle
Battlefield as fast as possible and
president zielinski has done an
interview with Kay Burley and he said
that overall I'm very thankful to the
world for this support for Ukraine but
speaking frankly the number of tanks and
the delivery time to Ukraine is critical
and he obviously thinks that look
pledging the tanks is the easy bit but
it's getting them over there that's
difficult I mean how long could it take
well as I said I'm no expert
unfortunately on how long it will take
the Germans or the Americans to get that
Hardware over there but clearly he's
absolutely right this needs to happen at
PACE if we are to get them into place
not just get them into place but get the
ukrainians trained up on how to use what
is certainly in the case of the leopard
and I think the Abrams is very
sophisticated tank so there's quite a
job to do to train people up to use
these and that's why he's absolutely
right we need to get this stuff over
there as quickly as possible and the
Kremlin has come back to say these tanks
will burn down like all the others and
the Russian Embassy in Berlin has
reacted to Germany's decision saying
it's an extremely dangerous one and an
escalation of the conflict is there a
risk it provokes well Russia has been
using this language of course right from
the beginning of what is an illegal
invasion of Ukraine which has brought
huge misery to its people and we need to
really see this through and we know that
the Russians are now looking to recruit
hundreds of thousands of additional
reserves to bring in as the weather
changes we as we approach the spring so
we've got to be ready for that so this
kind of rhetoric is is nothing new I'm
afraid but our resolve must be absolute
I was interested seals Johnson in
Ukraine again on Sunday meeting
President zlinsky how do you feel about
the former prime minister still being
the face of the UK's relationship with
Ukraine well he is one part of the UK's
face as you put it and of course I think
one has to
um applaud what Boris Johnson did in
making sure that our country was right
in the Vanguard of supporting Ukraine in
its darkest hour we were one of the
first countries to step up to the plates
and you know he clearly feels very
passionate about this and he's over
there lending his uh his moral support
and so on he's very close to president
zielinski so I think that's very
positive and that doesn't detract of
course from what the government is doing
and what this prime minister is doing
who is equally committed to making sure
that we stand by Ukraine and its people
I'm interested to talk to you about your
brief but just before we do and the
prime ministers asked his new ethics
advisor to investigate whether Nadine
zahawi broke the ministerial code how
long do you expect that to take I don't
know the answer to that but I do know
that they won't and he won't want to
hang around albeit that he will want to
be very thoroughly weeks come weeks
rather than money I really don't know
but I I I I I think in in a reasonable
period of time I think this is something
that one way or another we need to have
closure on the Prime Minister will want
to know all the facts so that when he
gets those facts he's in a position to
take a decision whatever that may be
um but we do need to leave the the
ethics advisor to do his work and make
sure that it is thorough and that all
the facts are presented to the Prime
Minister that's something you say
they're um about the Prime Minister
taking the decision so if Laurie Magnus
finds that Nadeem zahawi did breach the
ministerial code we'll receive the next
second I think that would be a very
difficult finding but I can't and it
wouldn't be right for me to attempt to
prejudge the outcome of this based on
hypotheticals we don't know what the
findings will be and until we do I think
we have to wait for those to come
forward and then wait to decide to see
what the the Prime Minister designs when
you say difficult finding what do you
mean by difficult finding well clearly
no Minister will want to be in a
position where they're found to be in
breach of the ministerial code but as to
the consequences of any particular
outcomes a I can't predict what those
would be and it'd be wrong for me to
speculate and B it wouldn't be right for
me to try and prejudge the prime
minister's decisions based on
theoretical outcomes I guess the
difficulty is that you know we're being
asked to be quiet until the inquiry uh
reports we don't know how long that's
going to be and also for public
confidence in the inquiry surely it's
important to say that everything is on
the table that if he's found a breach of
the code then there'll be consequences
well as I say safety I I'm not in a
position to start speculating as to what
may or may not be established but I
think the prime minister is doing
exactly the right thing which was when
he became aware of additional
information that wasn't available to him
at the time that he appointed in the
dean zahawi to the cabinet he took
prompt action in appointing his advisor
and asking him to establish the facts
and that's what that advice will do we
shouldn't rush him in in that endeavor
because the most important thing is that
it's done thoroughly but I know that the
Prime Minister will then look at those
facts very carefully and decide what he
decides to do I think it would be would
you agree it would be difficult if if
you say difficult if the inquiry does
find a breach of the code for the prime
minister to allow Nadine's heart to
sustain his job no I didn't say that
what I said was that if we had a
situation where any minister or indeed
any parliamentarian of any party finds
himself in a position where they breach
the ministerial code then of course
that's a difficult situation but it
depends on what it's for on the degree
and so on and so forth but as I say come
back to the substantial point which is
that we have to let the advisor now
carry out his work have a thorough uh
checking of all the facts presenting
those facts to the Prime Minister and
the Prime Minister then taking his
decision let's have an argument that all
high profile politicians members of the
cabinet should publish their tax returns
I don't personally think so
um because I think there are some things
in life which are justifiably a private
medical records for example would be
part of that as well even if they're you
know you're the guys deciding how much
tax everyone else should pay though is
there not a different degree well there
is a a procedure that the cabinet office
goes through when the prime minister is
forming his or her cabinet and those
kind of issues of propriety and ethics
so on it's a bit questionable effects
well yes I mean well well they are drawn
together for a variety of different
means including conversations with the
prospective cabinet uh uh Minister him
or herself so it is part of a process so
I I do think those things matter but do
I think that politicians generally
should be
um sort of summons to publish all their
tax Affairs their financial affairs or
their health
records or whatever else it may be I
think I think there is a limit to what
we should expect public figures to but
others have different views on that
um now there've been a lot of reports
this week talking to you with your
minister of hat on yeah about a plan to
raise the state retirement age to 68.
what's going on what's the truth well uh
the the truth of the matter is is as it
has been for some time now which is that
it is my responsibility to look at
taking that decision in conjunction with
others looking at the various reports
that have been around that issue and
taking into account a whole balance of
different elements when I come to that
decision including how long people are
expecting to live going forward into the
future and how that's changing Through
Time intergenerational fairness impact
on different protected groups and so on
and I will be coming forward with that
decision as I'm statutorily required to
no later than May of this year so that's
work that I'm actively considering at
the moment according to these reports
Jeremy Hunt the chance wants to bring
the retirement age forward and so it
wants to raise the retirement age which
makes sense because it means that you
know he gets more money in the treasury
you apparently are worried about the
plan potentially because of a fall in
life expectancy projections would make
it politically unfeasible according to
report is that your according to reports
whose reports
well as I say I I can't say any more and
in fact it would be totally improper for
me to start speculating as to where I
might want this to land okay considering
the evidence I've set out the basis I'm
going to have one more go one more okay
previous reports have said that people
should spend roughly a third of their
life retired do you think that's right I
think that's one of the metrics amongst
many others that one considers when
looking at this decision how long would
you is it reasonable for somebody to
have uh later on in life as a proportion
of their expected their life expectancy
but it's only one element of it and as I
say tempting there though it is uh I'm
not going to start you know being drawn
into okay specific thoughts understood
now when we last spoke we talked about
your efforts to try and get more people
back into work yeah I know that's a big
part of what you're doing yes including
the over 50s many of whom have taken
early retirement I guess my question is
if you don't have to work why would you
well one of the reasons why people over
the age of 50 but below retirement age
step out of the workforce is they've
taken a calculation that they've got
enough assets and income and money to
see themselves through perhaps indeed to
the rest of their lives but what we know
is that if you were born in 1970 you've
got a reasonable chance of reaching 100
in reasonable health so I think there is
therefore a possibility that some of
those that have taken that decision
would benefit from additional
information so you're saying that
they've made the wrong calculation well
actually yeah I think it's important
that everybody that makes the
calculation does it based on as much
information as possible and they they go
into that with their their eyes open so
I think there may be scope going forward
for providing more of that information
so people can make a more informed
choice we have actually seen a slight
decrease in economic inactivity more
recently and a lot of that has been
amongst the over 52 perhaps are
beginning to think about those things
particularly as times have been a bit
tougher okay thank you very much for
being on the program thank you